J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: So we've
started talking about the
mechanism about
carbonyl chemistry.
We'll talk today about addition
to carbonyl, the
mechanism, and the equilibrium
constant.
About protecting groups, a
little bit of NMR review at
the end if we have time.
And if we really have time, a
little bit about the next
topic, which is oxidation and
reduction as it involves
carbonyl groups and
electron transfers.
So last time we took an overview
of basic carbonyl
reactivity.
That you have addition.
You can have addition where the
nucleophile attacks,
that's the old Burgi-Dunitz
story.
And then the acid A comes on to
oxygen and you complete it.
Or you can do it the other
direction.
You can start with the acid
protonating the oxygen first.
Or whatever acid it is.
And then to give an oxygen
cation that's stabilized by
the double bond. You can a draw
resonance structure with plus
on carbon and the nucleophile
comes in.
So there are two ways of doing
it.
Initially with a nucleophile,
initially with an acid.
And we saw that if you have an
alpha hydrogen, then it's
possible to pull it off with
base to make an enolate and
put it on--
back on the oxygen.
So that's--
you can do an allylic
rearrangement to an enol.
It can be base-catalyzed, by the
enolate.
It also could be acid-catalyzed.
You could first put the proton
on the oxygen and take it off
the alpha carbon.
You can also, because of having
that functionality,
enolate anion at the alpha
carbon, or the double bond of
the enol, you can also do alpha
substitution.
So we'll see examples of that.
And if you have a leaving group,
the thing is called an
acid derivative, right?
And you can replace it by a
nucleophile, by--
in the two-step reaction, first
add to the carbonyl then
remove the nucleophile.
So nucleophilic substitution of
acid derivatives.
And in the case of carboxylic
acids you can have
addition, of course.
just as we did before.
You can have substitution at
carbon, where you make a
new carbon-oxygen bond.
Or you can have substitution at
oxygen, where you make a
new O-R bond.
And again, if you have an alpha
carbon it's possible to
do substitution at the alpha
carbon.
And we'll see examples of that.
Now, one particular example is
what's called Fischer
esterification which was
invented, you'll not be
surprised to hear, by Emil
Fischer.
And it's substitution at carbon
of a carboxylic acid to
convert it into an ester.
And it's acid-catalyzed.
So let's think about how this
works.
Where's the acid going to come
in and protonate this?
Karl?
STUDENT: At the oxygen.
PROFESSOR: There are two
oxygens.
STUDENT: Oh.
The oxygen that's connected by
the single bond.
PROFESSOR: How do you know?
Why should it do that one? why
not the other?
STUDENT: Because water's a good
leaving group, and so
that O just put the H...or you
put the proton on--
PROFESSOR: I'm not asking what's
a good leaving group.
I'm asking where the best place
to protonate is.
STUDENT: Um, from-- that O has--
that O has the unshared pairs.
PROFESSOR: How about the oxygen
on top?
STUDENT: That also has unshared
pairs, so--
PROFESSOR: Let's look at what
would happen, if you brought
the proton in on top.
You'd get that cation.
Anything good about that one
that you can't have if you
protonate the bottom one?
Anybody see?
Debbie?
STUDENT: Resonance?
PROFESSOR: You can get resonance
stabilization of that one.
Why protonate this one instead
of that one?
Well notice in the starting--
that this unshared pair is
stabilized by that.
By the low LUMO next door, so
that makes it a little harder
to protonate, right?
On the other hand, the one
that's up here is--
it could be a lower-energy one,
if it were in those
rabbit-ear sp square orbitals.
So that would suggest that this
one
might be better, right?
But it's killed by that.
And when you protonate--
but notice the stability you get
there gets even more so
when you protonate on the top.
Whatever stabilization you had
of this unshared pair before
you protonated it, you have more
now because you have a
lower LUMO to stabilize it.
So you get that special
stabilization, which you can
draw by a resonance structure,
that resonance structure.
So you in fact protonate the
top, not the bottom.
OK?
So once you've done that then
you can bring in an alcohol
and attack the carbon.
It's going to be easy to attack
now,
since a very low LUMO.
And then lose--
so you get a tetrahedral
intermediate.
You started with a trigonal
carbon, three
atoms attached to it.
Now there are four. It's a
tetrahedral intermediate.
So notice that as opposed to SN2
substitution, this one
first does an addition,
and then loses the leaving
group.
They're not both happening at
the same time.
In that sense it's analogous the
nucleophilic
aromatic substitution.
Here's a nucleophile that comes
in, forms a
tetracoordinated carbon, and
then this one is going to
leave. Here the amine came in,
formed a tetracoordinated
carbon, from the one that had
only three things when the
fluorine was down here.
And now this is strictly
analogous to that.
What we do next is lose a proton
from here, and then
lose the flouride.
Here we're going to lose a
proton from here
and then lose hydroxide.
So we lose the proton--
now, of course there's an easier
way than losing
hydroxide directly.
Now you can do what you want to
do, Karl.
STUDENT: Bring on the protons to
that oxygen.
PROFESSOR: To that-- to your
favorite oxygen there.
Now you've got the leaving
group.
But the first protonation was up
here and you went through
that tetrahedral intermediate.
It wasn't the case of making
this a leaving group, and then
doing something like an SN2.
You first did an addition to the
carbonyl and then
eliminate the water, and of
course the proton
then comes off again.
So that's the mechanism of
Fischer esterification.
And of course you can run it
either direction.
You can run it forwards or
backwards.
It's a way of replacing OR on
the acid carbon,
the carbonyl carbon.
And you can do it with where R
is H, as well as where R is
some alkyl group.
So you can go either way,
trading them back and forth.
So the way you decide to get
ester, rather than getting
acid, which way are you going to
go, is to have a lot more
alcohol than water there.
So you drive the equilibrium one
way.
If you turn it around and have a
lot more water than alcohol,
you'll drive it the other way.
OK.
So that's Fischer
esterification.
Now Victor Meyer, we saw last
time, was the short-term
supervisor of Moses Gomberg.
And remember what Gomberg did in
his lab?
He made tetraphenylmethane,
which was hard to make because
it was so sterically hindered,
as we found out in trying to
make it with models last time.
But in fact it was Victor Myer
who introduced the idea of
steric hindrance in 1894.
He wrote, "the source of this
behavior is stereochemical,
the space filling of the
neighboring groups." So this
was something else that was
added to the organic model in
the 19th century that we didn't
really
discuss last time.
We discussed configuration--
things involving arrangement
in space-- which was van't Hoff
in 1874.
We talked about strain, ring
strain.
That was Baeyer, 1885.
And we talked about conformation
which Sachse
tried, unsuccessfully, to
introduce into the
discussion in 1891.
But Meyer had the idea of steric
hindrance.
And he said the source of this
behavior.
What was this behavior?
What was it the basis of his
proposing steric hindrance?
It was Fischer esterification in
the situation where it
doesn't work.
So it doesn't work for
2,6-dimethylbenzoic acid.
When you have a methyl group
here and a methyl group here
adjacent to that, then you can't
do Fischer
esterification.
Now why not?
You can clearly start out here
by bringing in a proton and
putting it on there.
No problem.
Where do you get into trouble,
do you see?
Karl, try again.
STUDENT: When you're going to
bring in the OR group, because
it's going to have to attack
from that way.
PROFESSOR: It's going to have to
come in from here, where
this thing is.
And you're going to try to make
that into a tetrahedral
carbon with three extra
substituants on it.
So it's going to to have the--
it's going to have whatever just
came in, right?
Some OR group.
Plus, this one protonated and
this one protonated.
So you've got to get all these
three things here, where
that's not an H. That's whatever
just came in.
Adjacent to these two things,
and it's quite crowded as you
can see here, that there's going
to be strain involved in
these things running into one
another.
So you can't get to the
tetrahedral intermediate of
the Fischer esterification.
And this was actually the basis
of the first suggestion
that there was such a thing as
steric hindrance.
OK.
So this tetrahedral intermediate
is hard to make
if R is really big and crowded.
OK?
But there's a way to make the
ester, none the less.
And it was invented by a guy who
sat in some of your seats.
I don't know which seats he sat
in when he was a student
here because it was a long time
ago.
So we can't do that.
We can't do Fischer
esterification that way.
But Melvin Newman, whose picture
we showed last
semester, figured out in 1941
how to do this.
And he did it by putting the
acid into concentrated
sulfuric acid.
Now what happens when you put it
into
concentrated sulfuric acid?
Karl?
So you put it into concentrated
acid, it's going
to protonate it.
Where will it protonate it?
STUDENT: On the top.
PROFESSOR: On the top, right?
Wrong again.
No, actually you're right of
course.
You do protonate it up.
You put it in 100% sulfuric
acid, you do protonate it on
the top, right?
For the same reason we went
through before.
But once in a while--
you were right originally.
Once in a while, it'll protonate
on the bottom.
The one you wanted.
And what's good about that?
STUDENT: It's a leaving group.
PROFESSOR: It's a leaving group.
So in fact, that can now go
away.
Now of course it could come back
again.
But, in concentrated sulfuric
acid, water is all protonated.
And as long as it's protonated
it can't come back.
It doesn't have the high HOMO.
So in fact, you can make this
thing, which is called in an
acylium ion.
And now, what he does is take
this concentrated sulfuric
acid and pour it, carefully,
into water--
or pardon me, into alcohol.
So as he pours it into alcohol
it's no longer concentrated
sulfuric acid.
So the acid--
so you won't be able to make
these things anymore.
But alcohol rather than water is
the thing that
will get the carbon.
So then you'll--
that inhibits the reversal, as
we just said.
And you pour it into ROH and now
the OR traps it, and
you'll lose a proton, and you've
made the ester.
But notice the difference.
Here you made it by dissociation
followed by
association when it's crowded.
The normal Fishcer
esterification is association
and then dissociation.
But by doing it in real strong
sulfuric acid, Newman figured
out how to do this in the very,
very hindered cases.
OK.
So now, hydration of carbonyl
groups, which can be done
either acid or base.
And that was a note to myself
which I forgot to take out.
So let's talk about acid
catalyzed hydration of
formaldehyde.
So I want somebody to help me
out on here.
Here, down at the bottom, we
have formaldehyde and water.
And what I want to do is add to
get the hydrate, as it's
called, of the aldehyde right?
The diol.
That's a hydrate or a gem-diol,
the two OH's on the
same carbon.
So how do we do that?
Here we have--
it's acid catalyzed, it's
hydration, so we have water,
and it's formaldehyde.
How are we going to begin here?
Amy what do you say?
STUDENT: Umm--
PROFESSOR: It's acid catalyzed,
so
what's going to happen?
STUDENT: You're going to
protonate one of the--
PROFESSOR: So we're going to
protonate something.
So far, so good.
What are you going to protonate?
STUDENT: We're starting on that
side, right?
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
STUDENT: We're starting on that
side, right?
PROFESSOR: We're going to
protonate.
Where are we going to protonate
it?
STUDENT: The carbonyl group?
PROFESSOR: Where on the carbonyl
group?
Which atom?
STUDENT: The O.
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
So bring it down, we bring that
on, and now we have that,
which is a nice stable cation,
right?
It's a resonance stabilized.
OK.
What's going to happen next?
You want to keep us going?
STUDENT: Then the O on the H2O's
going to come in and
attack the cation.
PROFESSOR: OK, so that will come
in, attack the cation.
So now we got that.
And finally?
We're getting pretty close to
the product, what
do we have to do?
STUDENT: We have to deprotonate
the OH.
PROFESSOR: Right, so you just
have to lose the proton.
And it doesn't just fly off.
An alcohol will take it or
something.
OK.
Or water.
So we've done it.
So that's acid catalyzed
hydration of formaldehyde.
Now how about base catalyzed
hydration of formaldehyde?
Need someone to help us here.
Lauren, how about you?
So what's going to attack what?
STUDENT: Well...
PROFESSOR: We've got base for a
catalyst. Notice, we got the H
plus back again here.
It was catalytic, right?
Came in at first, then came out
again.
So OH minus is going to come in
at first,
and come out again--
it's base-catalyzed--
and we've got water, and we've
got an aldehyde.
What are we going to attack with
the OH?
STUDENT: Is it going to attack
the double bond?
PROFESSOR: Where will it attack?
STUDENT: The lone pair will
attack the pi*
PROFESSOR: On which atom, O or
C?
STUDENT: On the C.
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
PROFESSOR: On the C,
right. This is our old favorite
attacking pi*.
So that will come down there.
And now we got that.
But what we need is the hydrate,
the gem-diol.
So what's going to happen next?
What do we need in order to get
there?
To get from here to here, what
atom do we need?
STUDENT: A proton.
PROFESSOR: A proton.
Where do we get it?
STUDENT: From water.
PROFESSOR: From water.
It's in base, right?
So we're not going to get it
from H plus.
We're going to get it from
water.
So the water will come down, do
an SN2
type reaction at hydrogen--
substitution at hydrogen--
and we've got the product
and hydroxide which comes back
and catalyzes another one.
Lives to fight another day.
OK.
So either acid- or
base-catalyzed schemes
will work for that.
Now, how about independent of
which catalyst you use, there
is going to be an equilibrium
constant between water plus
the aldehyde, and the diol, the
gem-diol, the hydrate.
And as luck would have it, for
acetaldehyde, the one which
has CH3 and H on the carbonyl,
the
equilibrium constant is one.
And now we're going to see how
that equilibrium constant
changes as we change what kind
of aldehyde or ketone we're
dealing with.
OK.
So suppose we have formaldehyde.
I want someone to predict for me
whether this equilibrium
constant is going to be greater
than one
or less than one.
Can anybody see any factors that
will be relevant?
Alex, can you see a difference--
we want
differences between this and
this, or between this and
this, that it's going to make
one or the other more stable,
and therefore change the
equilibrium constant.
STUDENT: Well I guess the top
right one might be
crowded by the methyl.
PROFESSOR: Aha.
That's a good point.
This angle gets smaller here,
right?
So this CH3 could run into the
H. But also, the CH3 gets more
crowded because we've got two
O's on here now.
So that's a good point.
But it's the one that I've
animated second.
OK.
Which way is that going to
change it?
Is it going to make the
equilibrium constant greater or
less than one?
STUDENT: It'll make the bottom
one higher than one.
PROFESSOR: It'll make this one
less energetic than that was.
Lower in energy, so that'll tend
to shift it to the right.
OK?
Any other factors?
How about anything on the left?
Anybody see anything there?
Between this and this.
Notice that here we have an sp
squared bond to carbon and
here we have an sp squared bond
to hydrogen.
Karl?
STUDENT: Would the methyl be
more electron withdrawing?
PROFESSOR: Generally electrons
consider--
carbon is considered donating,
but that's not the factor.
The strength of bond, remember
the strength of the
carbon-carbon bond depends on
hybridization.
The strength of the
carbon-hydrogen bond depends on
hybridization.
But the carbon-carbon bond is
more sensitive to
hybridization, gets stronger
when you go sp squared than
the carbon-hydrogen does.
So this one was a stronger bond
than that one, with
respect to the sp squared
hybridization.
So that made this one low.
And this one was high originally
because of sterics,
as we said.
Now we've got--
this one is now higher, and this
one is lower.
So it should shift it to the
right, and indeed, both the
bond strength that we just
talked about, and the steric
hindrance both suggest that it
should shift to the right.
And it does.
It's 20,000, the equilibrium
constant.
Now let's try this way.
Let's look at acetone.
Two CH3s.
Now what do you think?
How about on the left?
Is this going to be better or
worse than before, than the
ones above?
Po-Yi.
STUDENT: As for bond strengths.
PROFESSOR: It's got two of these
carbon-carbon bonds that
are especially strong.
So this is good on the left.
How about on the right?
STUDENT: There is more steric
hindrance.
PROFESSOR: Right, there's even
more steric hindrance.
So that one should go to the
left from one.
And in fact it goes the other
way, right?
By a factor of a thousand
roughly.
OK.
Now let's look at this.
Let's put chlorine on the methyl
group on top.
Now, does anybody have any ideas
about that?
So the fact of the chlorine will
change this bond.
It'll also change that bond.
Because it's electron
withdrawing.
So where can it withdraw
electrons better from?
Can it withdraw electrons better
from an sp squared or
from an sp cubed bond?
Where does it withdraw better?
Cassie, you got an idea?
Which is the more likely to
donate electrons, sp cubed or
sp squared?
Which one is going to hold the
electrons tighter?
STUDENT: sp squared.
PROFESSOR: Right, the one with
more s will hold tighter and
not be willing to give them up.
So if chlorine wants to get
them, it's going to get them
better from here than from here.
So it should shift the
equilibrium in that direction.
So the electron donation-- and
it shifts it, not nearly by
factors of a thousand, but by
a factor of 37,
compared to when I had an H
instead of a chlorine.
Now, suppose we have
three chlorines.
Obviously the same direction
should happen.
But how big should it be?
Sebastian do you have an idea?
If one chlorine did 37, a factor
of 37--
so it changed the free-energy
difference enough to make a
factor of 37, what should two
more do?
What should one more--
suppose we just put one more in.
By what factor should we
increase it do you think?
Bear in mind that if you make
the same energy change, that
translates... because it's in an
exponent for an equilibrium,
the energy,
it's a certain factor,
because if you add things in
exponents it's like
multiplying things, right?
So if one changes it by 37, the
second one, if things are
simple, would change it by a
factor of 37.
And the third would change it by
another factor of 37.
So if we go all the way from one
to three, by what factor
should we increase the
equilibrium constant?
STUDENT: 37 squared.
PROFESSOR: 37 squared.
Is everybody me on that?
OK.
Now, 37 squared is a little
bigger than 1,000, right?
And look at that it's 28,000.
That's better than we had any
reason to expect.
But it makes sense.
And finally, what if we have
benzene as the substituant.
So benzaldehyde.
Is that going to shift it right
or
left, what do you think?
Arvind, do you have an idea?
Where will the phenyl be
stabilizing things more, on
the right or on the left?
STUDENT: Probably on the left.
PROFESSOR: Why?
STUDENT: Because there'll be
more resonance at the--
PROFESSOR: Right.
Because you're going to have
HOMO/LUMO interaction between
the carbonyl and the pi system
of benzene ring.
So it should shift things to the
left.
Conjugation should stabilize the
aldehyde,
and in fact it does.
It's a factor of 100, right?
Instead of one, it's 0.01.
So it shifted it to the left.
So all these make sense in terms
of what we understand of
what controls molecular energy.
OK now, acetal formation happens
only with acids.
And I think that this is the
one.
Oh no, OK.
Yeah, OK.
Now, so let's look at
acid-catalyzed hemiketal
formation from formaldehyde.
This is closely related to a
slide that I just showed you.
So what we have is, we want to
get from the
aldehyde to this, right?
a hemiketal.
And so what we-- it's
acid-catalyzed ROH is
going to add to this.
And how's it going to happen?
Well let's not mess around here.
Let's just go there, OK?
So we protonate just as we did
last time when
we were adding water.
Alcohol comes in, forms the
bond, bingo, we lose the
proton, it's catalytic, and we
have the product.
OK, nobody's surprised by that.
I'm doing the--
I'm belaboring this, I realize.
We did the same thing last time
essentially.
Or we did the reaction going the
other direction,
now I'm going back.
But it's really important that
you get this.
Now, base-catalyzed.
We can do this just like with
water, right?
We bring that in, attack the
pi*, get that.
It takes a proton this time from
alcohol,
instead of from water.
And we have the hemiketal.
So fine.
OK.
But suppose what we wanted to do
was get the
ketal, not the hemiketal,
OK?
Now, notice that that proton can
attack either oxygen.
It could either protonate OR, in
which case what would
happen if you then broke a bond?
You see which way-- where you're
going if you protonate
OR and then break the bond
between O and C. Have alcohol
leave. Amy?
STUDENT: Would you go back?
PROFESSOR: You're going right
back where you started.
But you can protonate this one
as well as that one.
So if you protonate this one and
lose water, then instead
of reversing, you can continue.
So you lose water and you get
that stable cation,
Just like this stable cation
except it has an R on it
instead of the H. And then you
bring another alcohol in, and
do your trick, and you've got
the full ketal.
Fine.
We talked last time we went--
spent a lot of time going from
the ketal
back to the carbonyl.
Now we're just going the other
direction,
reversing all of them.
Now let's try to do the same
thing with base catalysis, is
it going to work?
What's the first step going
backwards for base catalysis?
If we want to start from here
and go backwards, what's the
first thing that happens?
Linda?
STUDENT: It deprotonates.
PROFESSOR: The base will pull
off the proton, right?
Here the acid could protonate
either oxygen.
But here, when the base has to
pull off a proton, there's
only one to pull off.
It can't pull it off from the R.
And you can't do an SN2--
pulling the R off would be like
doing an SN2 reaction,
where hydroxide attacks the R,
and this O leaves.
But that's a terrible leaving
group.
That's not a good one.
So it can only take--
so the ether--
ethers are inert to base.
They don't under go SN2
reactions.
So it can only reverse, it can't
go on.
So you can get a ketal by acid
catalysis.
But you can only get a hemiketal
with base catalysis.
And furthermore, not only is
there no way to get the ketal,
but you can't attack the ketal
with base either.
Once you've got the ketal, it
won't attack with base,
because you can't attack ethers
with a base.
So it's the old joke, "You can't
get there from here."
Base will not do it with ketals,
either making them or taking
them apart again.
OK.
Now, this relates to protecting
groups.
And I'm going to do this on the
board.
If I were talking about pedagogy
I would say it's good
for me occasionally to draw
these things, just so you can
see a human draw them, rather
than have them
all animated there.
But in fact I didn't have time
to do this last night.
So there we go.
So let's take this up a bit.
So we're going to look at ketals
as protecting groups.
Just a couple examples.
There are plenty of examples in
the book.
Now, a particularly interesting
compound is
glucose, which is an aldehyde,
and an alcohol.
In fact it has many alcohol
groups.
It's got OH here, OH here, OH
here, OH here.
Now remember, the ketal, or
hemiketal, is formed by
reaction of an alcohol with the
aldehyde.
But now we don't have to add an
alcohol. We've got alcohols
in there already to react with
the aldehyde.
In fact, we've got plenty of
them.
And the question is, which one?
Now if we were to react this
oxygen to make a ring with
this carbon, then how many atoms
would be in the ring?
How big a ring would it be?
It would have the oxygen--
one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven.
It would be a 7-membered ring.
7-membered rings are not so easy
to form because they
pucker up and things, and on
opposite sides
run into one another.
So that's not so good.
Obviously if you use this one to
attack the carbon, it would
be a 3-membered ring.
That's bad.
That's strain.
This one would be a 4-membered
ring.
But this one would be a
5-membered ring,
that's not so bad.
This one would be a 6-membered
ring and that's good.
So let's see how we can do that.
If we made a hemiketal, we could
have C, OH, H, COH, COH.
I'll just draw it that way.
COH I'll draw it that way.
C, and now--
and down here is CH2OH.
And now, this oxygen has to go
to there.
So I could draw it this way.
But nobody thinks I'm trying to
draw what it
actually looks like.
In fact, it's a 6-membered ring.
It would look like a
cyclohexane.
But, just for purposes of
showing what's bonded to what,
it's often drawn that way.
OK.
So that would be a hemiketal.
And it's 6-membered ring,
6-ring, and that thing is
called a pyranose, when it's a
6-membered ring.
Now if it were this carbon, then
we would have C, H, OH,
and we can come down here and
we'd have CH2OH, and we'd have
OH here, and we'd have CH, O
coming out, O here.
And we'd have OH and OH.
And this would be one, two,
three, four,
5-membered ring.
And that's called a furanose.
OK.
So it could go either way, and
they're reversible, too.
Because we know that with either
acid- or base-catalysis
you can go back and forth
between hemiketals and the
carbonyl group.
OK.
Now how could you find out which
ring size it is?
Well the way it's actually done
nowadays is by NMR. But,
in the old days, when they
didn't have NMR, they had to
do chemical transformations to
figure out what was what.
So chemical degradation.
So one thing they could do would
be to treat it with acid
and alcohol, say methanol.
So acid can protonate an OH, and
then lose
water to leave a cation.
But it turns out that only one
of the--
that one of the OH's reacts much
more
rapidly than the others.
Which one is easy to protonate
and lose water, so as to
generate a stable cation?
OK.
If we-- say we protonated this
one, for example.
We'd generate a secondary
cation.
Protonate this one, secondary
cation, this one, secondary
cation, this one, primary
cation--
not so good.
This one-- what would happen if
we protonated that one, and
lost water?
I'll write it down below here.
So we had OH, H, this O down
here, et cetera.
Suppose I protonated this one
and lost water.
Here is the cation I would get.
And then I could bring methanol
in to put the oxygen
on there, lose the proton from
methanol, and I would have
made what functional group?
If I now have O--
instead of OH up here I have
OCH3.
Everyone sees how I did that,
don't I?
It's the same thing we've been
doing all the time.
You protonate, lose water, put
the alcohol on, lose proton.
That replaces OH with OR.
Why did it do it there and not
do it at
all these other places?
What was specially good about
this cation that the others
didn't have?
Chris?
Let me draw the--
I'll draw the cation here, or
here.
So the cation has an O on it, an
H on it, a
carbon on it, +.
What's good about-- and this one
goes
down then to the bottom.
What's good about that cation,
Chris?
STUDENT: Secondary cation.
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
PROFESSOR: It's secondary if you
want to consider an oxygen
as if it were carbon, but so
were all
these others secondary.
Right?
If you protonated those and lost
water.
What's especially good about
this one? Matt?
STUDENT: You have an
electron-withdrawing oxygen.
PROFESSOR: Is that good to make
a cation if you have
something that's electron
withdrawing?
That means it's already
positive.
It doesn't want to get
more positive.
STUDENT: Oh.
PROFESSOR: So the electron
withdrawal by the oxygen is
going to be bad for this.
But there's something that
makes it good.
Brandon?
STUDENT: The lone pair mixes
with the carbon.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The unshared pair on the oxygen
is stabilized by this
vacant orbital, right?
You can draw a resonance
structure that puts
a double bond here.
And + on the oxygen.
OK.
So this one is the one that's
reactive to make a ketal.
This thing is a ketal.
It's got two OR groups on it.
And that one we could make a
ketal too, up here of course,
and not the other places.
So we can make a ketal, right?
Now, it's possible under those
circumstances to do reactions
with alcohols to chew up the
other alcohols, but not chew
up this one.
Because that alcohol is now in
the form of OCH3.
We'll talk about reactions next
class that involve
reactions of alcohols.
Oxidation for example.
OK.
So this is protecting that
particular carbon from being
reacted by having a full ketal
there.
Now, then you can take it apart
again by treating it
with acid and water.
Get it back and see what
compound you have. Which of
the oxygens in that chain got
oxidized and which ones were
not oxidized.
Compare with known compounds and
you know what the size of
the ring was.
Because notice that this--
not only did this group keep...
this OH keep from getting
oxidized, this OH,
that is this OH, didn't get
oxidized on this side, right?
And this OH didn't get oxidized
there.
So the protection protects not
only the aldehyde from being
oxidized, it also protects the
alcohol.
Professor Ziegler, who we've
mentioned, who teaches Chem
220 often, is a synthetic
chemist and always, when he
teaches a class in synthesis he
always points this out.
That people have tunnel vision
often.
They think of ketals as
something that
protects the carbonyl.
But it also protects an alcohol
at the same time
that's tied up as an ether and
won't do the reactions that
the alcohol would do.
So you not only protect a
carbonyl, you
also protect the ROH.
And a particular example of that
is what's called THP
protection.
So this compound can be reacted
with
ROH and acid catalysis.
So how's it going to start out?
Derek, you tell us.
Where are you going to protonate
this?
STUDENT: The O?
PROFESSOR: You could protonate
this O, you could protonate
this O, right?
Either of them particularly
good?
There's actually another place
to protonate that's very good.
Can anybody see?
Arvind?
STUDENT: On the carbon-carbon
double bond?
PROFESSOR: Where, top or bottom?
STUDENT: Umm, bottom.
PROFESSOR: Nope.
STUDENT: The top.
PROFESSOR: Top.
OK, if we put the H plus here,
why is that good?
Got the H here, there are now
two H's there, of course.
There was one there already.
What's good about that cation?
Matt?
STUDENT: Stabilized by the lone
pair on the oxygen.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You can say--
that's what everybody always
says, that it's stabilized by
the lone pair on the oxygen.
But actually what it does is
stabilize the lone pair on the
oxygen, which makes the molecule
more stable.
You're right, that's what
everyone says, that it's
stabilized by the lone pair.
But in truth, it stabilizes the
lone pair.
OK, so we got this.
Now we got ROH, what's it going
to do?
John?
What's the ROH going to do now
when you add that cation?
STUDENT: It'll-- the lone pair
on the oxygen will attack it.
PROFESSOR: And then what?
STUDENT: And then it'll lose H.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Lose proton, right?
So we got this.
And what functional group is
this that we now have?
Does anybody recognize this
functional group?
It's familiar.
Lee?
It's a ketal, right?
Two ethers on the same carbon.
But we didn't make it from a
carbonyl, we made it this way.
OK, so now we could do
reactions.
Suppose this R had something
else coming off that was going
to react, maybe a double bond.
And we wanted to react that, but
we didn't want to react
the alcohol.
But the ether keeps the alcohol
safe.
We do the reaction down here.
Now we need to get the alcohol
back again, having done what
we wanted to do down here.
How are we going to get it back?
How can we remove this stuff?
We can protonate.
Protonate the O, lose this,
generate this nice stable
cation again, go back.
We'd just go back and forth,
right?
With water.
Go back with water.
So we can make--
so this is a protecting group
for an alcohol,
to keep it from reacting.
I'll mention one other
protecting group for alcohols
here because they mention it in
the text book that many of
you have, which is called TBDMS.
It's
t-butyldimethylsilyl.
So t-butyl, dimethyl, silyl.
And you start with the chloride.
Now the chloride has a bond
strength, this bond, of
90 kcal/mole.
But you could react it with ROH
and the unshared pair will
react to form a bond with
silicon, right?
So now the silicon has five
things attached to it.
But then the chloride can leave.
It's not an SN2 reaction.
It's an association, followed by
dissociation.
Because silicon down in the next
row of the periodic table
has vacant orbitals that can
make a bond with that.
So now we've got t-butyl, Si,
methyl methyl, O, R. And the
strength of the SiO bond is 110
kcal/mole.
So this is downhill in energy.
OK.
Now, so now you can do what you
want to do, other things
in the R group, without
touching--
it's not an alcohol anymore.
It's a little bit like an ether.
But the neat thing is that
there's a special
way to take it apart.
You can take it apart by
treating it with
tetramethylammonium, methyl, 4N
plus, a salt,
but the business end is
fluoride.
Because fluoride can attack the
silicon the same way the
unshared pair on oxygen did
here.
And then you can protonate and
lose the OR.
So this is the nice thing-- the
product from the silicon
is now S-- which you don't
really care about--
is the Si-F, and the Si-F bond
is a fabulous bond.
It's 135 kcal/mole.
Plus now your ROH, once
you've protonated it.
So the nice thing about this is
there's not many things
that react with fluoride easily.
It's a terrible nucleophile
generally.
So now you have something that's
very selective, that
will only do that and take this
protecting group off and
not mess up other things that's
in your R group.
And this was invented in the
1970s by a professor at
Harvard who got the Nobel Prize
in Synthetic Chemistry,
Professor Corey.
So that's those things.
And now imines and their
derivatives, and the role of
electron pair repulsion and
allylic stabilization.
So I'm going to just introduce
this here, and we'll
finish it next time.
So we have a carbonyl, and we've
been reacting it with
alcohols or water.
But let's consider reacting with
an amine, which actually
has certain similarity to water,
of course.
It's got the unshared pair, and
protons on the nitrogen
the way alcohol has protons on
the oxygen.
So this can react,
and of course that can lose a
proton here, and it can put a
proton on there.
It's probably not the same
proton.
And this is called a carbinol
amine.
What's the analog when you have
an oxygen
instead of NH in there?
What functional group is it?
If this were just an O instead
of an NH, what would you call
this functional group?
I see you're all bored.
It's a hemiketal.
That's what we've just been
talking about.
But the carbinol amine is the
amine analog.
Now you can do--
because you have this hydrogen
here, you can
do something special.
You can lose this OH, say
protonate and lose it, helped
out by this.
And we get this,
and water.
Pardon me, it would be
originally NH plus when we use
the unshared pair,
but then we can lose the H plus.
So now we have this functional
group,
which is called an imine, which
is rather like a ketone.
So we got rid of the oxygen and
replaced with NR, and the
oxygen became H2O, by this same
kind of
stuff we've been doing.
So these imines turn out to be
very important, not only in
organic chemistry, but also in
biology.
And we'll continue with that
next time.
Or actually--
yeah, we'll continue with that,
but there will be no
more on the exam on Friday than
what we've done today.
OK.
STUDENT: Do we need to know
about the amines?
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
STUDENT: We need to know about
the amines?
PROFESSOR: Oh, forget the
amines, OK?
Just do the ketals and
hemiketals.
Imines will be on the final.